Prof: So I'm not sure
how long this lecture is going
to be.
We could be finished in ten
minutes,
though I doubt that,
and if we're not finished at
the end of the fifty,
there are some things that I've
reserved for the end of the
lecture that I definitely do
want to get said.
I don't know if you've noticed
that there are times when the
last point or two that I
appeared to have been preparing
to make never get made,
but in this case I want to make
sure that they are made so that
if I don't finish today,
or if I still have a point or
two to make,
I'll definitely be taking up
those points at the beginning of
Thursday's lecture.
All right.
Now the African-American
tradition of literary production
is rich and long standing.
As Henry Louis Gates tells you,
the first really rather
important poet in the tradition,
Phillis Wheatley,
is an American colonial writer.
The flourishing of the slave
narrative form begins in the
eighteenth century,
continues into the nineteenth,
the nineteenth century
witnesses extraordinary works of
fiction,
and in the twentieth century,
of course most conspicuously in
the Harlem Renaissance,
but throughout the century
there has been extraordinary
work done in the
African-American literary
tradition.
It's a very rich tradition--in
other words,
somewhat in contrast with the
very rich but also very recent
tradition of African-American
literary theory and criticism.
It's possible to argue that the
development of theory and
criticism in this tradition was
somewhat balked by a preliminary
way in which it found itself at
odds with itself.
Black criticism and black
feminist criticism from the
beginning saw that they didn't
have quite the same agenda.
This is something that can
resonate,
perhaps, later in this lecture
when we move to other topics,
but in the meantime critics
like Barbara Christian,
Barbara Smith,
Hazel Carby,
and Bell Hooks were in their
variety of ways working with
emphases that other,
male African-American critics
weren't quite comfortable with.
So while work,
especially beginning in the
eighties,
proliferated,
there was, as I say,
a kind of internal divide which
has been a complex matter to
negotiate and which is,
I think, now largely sort
of--well,
détente has been
achieved,
and African-American literary
theory is moving forward
unfettered any longer by these
concerns,
or at least by any excess of
these concerns.
But in the meantime that may
partly account for a certain
delay in the emergence of theory
and criticism given the
long-standing richness of the
literary tradition.
Now the role of Henry Louis
Gates in African-American
criticism is,
it seems to me,
exemplary, although there are
some rather harsh moments in
this essay,
moments that I wish to take up,
that would suggest an element
of--
what shall I say?--extremism or
overkill in Gates's thinking.
This is actually not at all the
persona that he has projected.
Indeed what's extraordinary
about Gates, whose
administrative power and whose
abilities as a program builder
are remarkable.
After he left Yale to go to
Harvard,
he was able to gather to
Harvard Anthony Appiah,
Cornel West,
and others who have since
departed from Harvard,
but Gates is in a way an empire
unto himself and he has been an
extraordinary figure.
The earliest work,
which is actually among the
earliest work in
African-American criticism,
is what you've been reading for
today,
and it established his
reputation together with--
not so much discovery of,
but authentication of--
a manuscript by Harriet Wilson
which he published,
an important contribution to
our knowledge of
nineteenth-century
African-American literature.
In any case,
what happened then was that
Gates who by some miracle or
other--
he was a perfectly good writer
in the first place but gradually
became a marvelous writer--
began writing for The New
Yorker,
and during this phase of
his career,
when among other things he
produced a remarkable
autobiography about growing up
in West Virginia,
during this phase Gates really
became a spokesperson for a
détente among races
and racial factions.
In other words,
he was a voice of moderation
without incurring any imputation
of Uncle Tom-ism or anything of
the sort.
His sheer urbanity as the
remarkable writer that he is in
those years when he wrote under
Tina Brown for The New Yorker
was just a remarkable
achievement,
and his career is still going
strong.
Now for Gates,
as for Elaine Showalter last
week and for Woolf before her,
the problems surrounding the
concept of identity persist.
Identity--which of course is an
important anchor for the
thinking of people who feel the
need for voices,
for a place in the literary and
cultural horizon--
is nevertheless at least
potentially,
as we've begun to notice
already, a kind of quicksand.
There are two problems really
that dog the issue of identity.
One of them is the problem of
"essentializing"
which I'll take up now,
and then, as I'll take it up
next, also the problem of what
might be called the identity
queue.
In other words,
I am a lower-class black
lesbian feminist whose nation is
Palestine.
Needless to say,
I have a variety of identity
options to choose from,
but the result is I've got to
figure out which of them has
priority.
In other words,
which of those identities do I
suppose has the underlying
integrity and essence,
essentiality,
that can motivate,
as it were, the characteristics
of my other identities,
which are therefore somehow or
another placed further down in
the queue?
So this is a topic that I'll
come back to in a minute,
but in the meantime the problem
of essentializing,
as we call it:
for example,
as Gates describes it on page
1893 in the right-hand column,
where he's very clear on the
dangers of ascribing,
whether positively or
negatively, attributes to any
group that is constituted as or
thought of--
because of course,
the notion of race and whether
there is race is in
itself according to Gates
problematic--
the problem of ascribing
attributes even honorifically to
a race is,
as he describes it on page
1893:
The sense of difference defined
in popular usages [finally my
voice is changing]
>
of the term race has
been used both to describe and
inscribe differences of
language,
belief system,
artistic tradition,
"gene pool,"
and all sorts of supposedly
"natural"
attributes such as rhythm,
athletic ability,
cerebration,
usury,
and fidelity.
In other words,
obviously, apportioning out
stereotypes to the various
groups that may come forward as
candidates to be races--
he's pointing out that all of
these stereotypes do nobody very
much good.
So the problem of
essentializing,
which undergirds the wish to
make manifest the existence of
race gives pause.
Think about it.
On the other hand,
Gates seems to be divided at
the beginning of his essay
between a certain candor about
race,
as in the work of Hippolyte
Taine that he describes,
in which "race,"
"milieu"
and "cultural moment"
are considered the key
determining issues of any kind
of artistic or cultural
production.
He says of that in effect,
"Well,
at least race is being talked
about," while at the same
time obviously wincing away from
the implications of race and
from the belief that there is
such a thing as race,
which goes all the way back to
Montesquieu and others from
Taine.
Nevertheless,
as I say, he's rather cheerful
about the fact that at least
race is being discussed,
unlike the twentieth century
when the whole thing is swept
under the rug and a kind of
ersatz and hypocritical
politeness prevents anybody from
talking about such categories at
all,
and gives rise to the idea that
we all exist in the same Great
Tradition,
that work either belongs to
that tradition or,
if it for some reason seems
egregious or outside the
tradition,
it just can be shoved aside and
neglected.
That's the supposition of the
twentieth century when folks
don't talk about race.
So the very question whether it
is an issue is part of this
problem that is dogged by the
more complicated issue of
essentializing.
For example,
suppose--and of course,
you've been reading about this
in Showalter as well--
you ascribe positive value to
what another person might call a
stereotype.
This is what the important
Francophone African poet Senghor
does, as Gates says at the top
of page 1901,
the right hand-column.
Gates says:
When we attempt to appropriate,
by inversion,
race as a term for an
essence,
as did the Negritude movement,
for example ("We feel,
therefore we are,"
as Senghor argued of the
African),
we yield too much,
such as the basis of a shared
humanity.
Such gestures,
as Anthony Appiah has observed,
are futile and dangerous
because of their further
inscription of new and bizarre
stereotypes.
So you can see there are a lot
of landmines to be avoided in
negotiating the discourse of
race, and certainly Gates is
aware of them.
Now there's also the problem,
as I say,
of the identity queue,
and Gates himself may have a
little difficulty with this,
at least from time to time,
because as I said at the
beginning,
he does have this sort of
uneasy détente
with feminism in the
African-American critical
tradition still to work within.
So for example,
on page 1894,
a somewhat problematic passage
in which the identity queue
seems to be at issue,
about a third of the way down,
the left-hand column,
he says:
The sanction of biology
contained in sexual difference,
simply put, does not and can
never obtain when one is
speaking of "racial
difference."
Yet we carelessly use language
in such a way as to will
this sense of natural
difference into our
formulations.
So what he's saying is in
biological terms there's
definitely a difference between
the sexes,
but in biological terms there
is not necessarily a difference
among the so-called primary
races.
The result is that at least
when one speaks of women and men
in the feminist tradition,
one has to come face to face
with the problem of actual
difference;
whereas when one speaks of
black and white in the
traditions of discourse about
race, one isn't actually talking
about a genuine difference at
all.
Therefore the discourse with
the greater integrity of the two
is the one which is about
differences that are absolutely
ephemeral,
as opposed to the one which is
about differences,
which, whatever one thinks of
them and whatever one wants to
make out of them,
are nevertheless essential.
Now plainly when we go back to
feminist criticism,
particularly the gender theory
of Judith Butler,
we'll see of course that the
whole question of the biological
basis of sex,
the biological difference
between the sexes which
essentializes what we will be
wanting to talk about,
is of course something that is
profoundly in question,
and not just because of
so-called trans-gender issues
but also,
at the same time,
because of the way in which our
very sexual identity is
something which,
according to Butler,
we construct.
So there is an insistence here
on a biological difference
between these two forms of
discussing identity which may or
may not seem to us to be
problematic.
Now I think this is the point
at which we can see the
importance of the extraordinary
essay that I've also asked you
to read, by Toni Morrison.
We know her best,
of course, as a novelist,
but she's also a distinguished
critic, as she has been a
distinguished editor of other
important work.
Here it seems to me that her
reflections in some ways give us
a sideways exit from the
predicaments that I have been
talking about,
the problem of essentialism and
the problem of the identity
queue,
because what Morrison wants to
say--
and I think she borrows here
particularly from the famous
discussion of the master-slave
dialectic in Hegel's
Phenomenology of Mind--
what Morrison wants to say
is that identity isn't so much a
question of what something is
but rather a question of what it
is not.
She says not that we should be
so much preoccupied with what it
is to be black,
but rather that,
as we think about the way in
which being black is inscribed
within the white tradition--
as we think about that,
we need to think about what
white is not:
in other words,
as she says repeatedly,
about black as absence,
as negation, as negativity.
We have to understand the
absolute--
and this is where she drives
her argument from the
master-slave dialectic--
the absolute necessity in the
construction of white identity
for there to be,
as an absence and as a lack
over against white identity,
the existence of the African
American and,
more particularly,
for the better part of the
American cultural tradition,
of the slave.
Let me quote then from her
essay on page 1795,
the left-hand column,
where she says:
In that construction of
blackness [this is a third of
the way down]
and enslavement could be found
not only the not-free but also
the projection of the not-me.
The result was a playground for
the imagination.
And what rose up out of
collective needs to allay
internal fears and rationalize
external exploitation was an
Africanism--
a fabricated brew of darkness,
otherness,
alarm and desire--that is
uniquely American.
Then she points out that
although her subject is the
American tradition,
there also exists a European
Africanism with its counterpart
in its own colonial literature.
To reinforce this,
she takes a remarkable example
which must have reminded you,
those of you who know Faulkner,
of Thomas Sutpen or at least
reminded you in some ways of
Thomas Sutpen--
the example of this character
Dunbar,
who actually rose up not so
much out of the swamp as out of
the Scottish Enlightenment and
came to the United States and--
according to Bernard Bailyn,
the historian from whom she
cites her information--
became a completely transformed
character.
I won't quote to you the long
passage from Bailyn's text which
makes what Morrison wants to
take from it clear,
but rather from what Morrison
summarizes of it on page 1796,
the top of the right-hand
column:
I take this [William Dunbar]
to be a succinct portrait of
the process by which the
American as new,
white, and male was
constituted.
It is a formation that has
several attractive consequences,
all of which are referred to in
Bailyn's summation of Dunbar's
character and located in how
Dunbar feels "within
himself"--
"a power,
a sense of freedom he had not
known before."
This is uncannily parallel by
the way to the rationalization
for slaves in Greek culture.
The Greeks always said that the
reason they had slaves was so
they could be free:
in other words so that the home
or ruling population was
liberated in the case of the
Greeks from performing the daily
necessities that are life
sustaining and keep us going.
In other words,
to be free according to the
citizen of the Greek
polis is to be free from
work.
Now in a certain way,
this is still a rationalization
that Tony Morrison sees in the
American slave-owning tradition,
but it's not so much in the
case of this Dunbar a freedom
from work.
It's a more broad and insidious
idea of freedom:
freedom from responsibility,
freedom from the need to
acknowledge otherness as human--
freedom, in other words,
from the sorts of constraint
imposed by old world civility in
Scotland and in London;
freedom on this frontier,
in this wilderness,
in this swamp,
simply to be whatever one wants
to be.
That freedom is achieved on the
backs of the black slaves.
It is in some ways similar,
as I say,
to the rationalization for
slavery in Greece,
but it is in a way more
insidious and certainly more--
in the terms that Morrison's
giving it to us in--
more dialectical.
That is to say,
it is the question of whether a
person could become white
without the availability of a
black absence,
of that which can be
oppressed-- like a kind of
spring for the jack-in-the-box--
which allows the white
jack-in-the-box to leap out of
the box because of that which
has been suppressed down below.
All of that is part of Toni
Morrison's concern,
and it colors her,
well, certainly controversial
reading of Huckleberry
Finn--
which nevertheless,
it seems to me,
has a quite profound interest.
Now my own first instinct when
people single out Huckleberry
Finn for blame is to
wince away, because it's an
extraordinary novel.
The controversy about it in the
school districts which made it a
banished book had mainly to do
with the "N-word,"
to which we'll return,
and the question of who has the
right to use the
"N-word,"
which is not an easy question
to answer,
as we'll see.
But that controversy,
while it had an authentic
basis,
was nevertheless certainly in
literary terms and in terms of
the imagination perhaps rather
limited.
Morrison gives rise to another
equally and intensely critical
way of thinking about
Huckleberry Finn.
She argues that to liberate
Jim--
which of course is the
tremendous failure at the end of
the novel,
a failure of imagination on the
part of Tom Sawyer and a failure
of will or independence of mind
on the part of Huck himself--
that the failure to liberate
Jim, which would have been the
easiest thing in the world,
because all they had to do was
point out the right fork in the
river,
is an absolute necessity for
the ongoing self-definition of
whiteness as it's available both
to Tom and to Huck and,
after all, by implication,
to Mark Twain himself.
He couldn't figure out how to
end the novel.
He wrote it,
then it lay on his desk for a
long time because he just
couldn't figure out what to do
with it,
and he finally comes up with
this--as we all agree--
appalling ending.
Toni Morrison says it's the
only ending available
because in ways that the,
as she sees it,
sentimentality of the novel and
the sentimentality of the
relationship between Huck and
Jim,
which is so strong that it
caused another critic named
Leslie Fiedler to talk about a
homoerotic relation between
them--
the title of Fiedler's famous
essay is "Come Up on the
Raft,
Huck, Honey"--with all of
that in the background,
Toni Morrison says the basic
structure of consciousness in
Twain's novel is obscured,
a basic structure which makes
it absolutely imperative that
Jim not be free.
If Jim is free,
then there is no Other over
against which whiteness can
define itself.
That's the way in which she
makes use of the general
argument about the traditions of
American literature in culture
in applying it to Huckleberry
Finn.
All right.
Let's go back to Skip
Gates--Henry Louis Gates's
nickname, sorry--another person
who was at Yale and whom I knew
very well.
I actually had a little bit to
do with the origin of the notion
of the signifying monkey;
I'll come back to that later.
Barbara Johnson,
also now at Harvard,
and I had a lot of
conversations with Skip at that
period about this,
and so it's not that I feel
proprietary--
it's Skip's idea--but I was in
on that,
and so it's not just name
dropping.
I get to call him by what his
friends call him.
However, I'll try to remember
to say Henry Louis Gates,
and in any case to return to
him now.
I want to talk a little bit
simply about his understanding
and the understanding of others
of the African-American
tradition--
both of the critical tradition
and of the literary tradition.
First of all,
the grasp of the critical
tradition as basically a
two-step or two-part progression
is something that he shares with
Elaine Showalter from last time.
You remember Showalter says
that the important movement of
feminist interventions in
literary criticism begins with
the moment that she calls
"feminist":
that is to say,
the moment of Kate Millett and
other authors who talk about the
degradation and unfair treatment
of women in male books,
and then what Showalter prefers
and supposes to have supervened
and to have become more
important,
"gynocritical
criticism,"
which is women's appropriation
of literary traditions for
themselves,
the archival work that makes
the canon of women's literature
not just leaping from great name
to great name,
but an actual unfolding and
continuous development from
decade to decade,
as Showalter puts it.
Now Gates on page 1896,
the right-hand margin,
sees it in much the same way
for the development of
African-American criticism.
You can do two things
basically, says Gates.
He doesn't put them
chronologically,
but you could map onto what
he's saying here the same
chronological sequence.
He says: What I mean by citing
these two overworked terms [he's
talking about "the
other" in particular]
is precisely this:
how blacks are figures in
literature [that is to say,
how they're represented in
literature,
demeaningly,
even perhaps honorifically],
and also how blacks
figure, as it
were,
literature of their own making.
[You can see,
in other words,
the same movement in his
thinking about these issues.]
As Showalter argued too,
the question of the
literary tradition is
more complicated;
it has more steps.
In other words,
the powers of self-expression
available to women from the
beginning of their creative
expression passed through more
than just two stages,
and the same thing is true of
African-American literature.
Now I think that Gates simply
takes for granted as an implicit
premise of the work that was
done the year before he
published this essay in
Critical Inquiry by
another colleague of ours here
at Yale--
who died tragically not too
long thereafter--
named Michael Cooke,
who in 1984 wrote a book called
Afro-American Literature in
the Twentieth Century:
The Achievement of
Intimacy.
Cooke argued in this book that
the history of African-American
literature passes essentially
through four stages.
It begins with what Cooke calls
"self-veiling":
the period,
in other words,
in which people attempting for
the first time to write--
and of course Gates talks about
the way in which writing is
really writing oneself into the
human community for black
people--
the people who first attempted
to write used white models.
Phillis Wheatley,
the poet whom Gates talks
about,
a remarkable poet and a very
interesting one,
nevertheless wrote in the
manner of Alexander Pope,
so much so that a great deal of
her work is almost impossible--
which is course a point of
praise--to distinguish from that
of Alexander Pope.
She is an instance of the first
phase, which Cooke calls
"self-veiling."
The second phase,
which Cooke calls
"solitude,"
involves continuing to use
white models,
a white prose style,
a way of narrating which is
obviously derived from white
teachers and white models but
which nevertheless involves,
as its central theme,
self-definition.
Here you might want to think of
Douglass and of slave narratives
in general,
where the emphasis is on being
taught by white people,
but nevertheless there is a
tension which exists and which
founds and governs the
possibility of self-liberation
and self-freedom.
In other words,
the slave narrative as an
ongoing form partakes of this
second phase in the development
of African-American literature
as Cooke understands it.
Thirdly, there is what Cooke
calls "kinship,"
a literature in which African
Americans reach out to each
other,
identify themselves as a
community,
not as individuals struggling
to be free but rather as a
community.
Cooke identifies this phase
with the experimentation with
dialect and a way of narrating
and poetizing which involves a
self-conscious insistence on
verbal and linguistic
difference.
You can think of many of the
poems, for example,
of Langston Hughes in this
regard and of a great deal else
that goes on in the Harlem
Renaissance;
so that's the third phase,
kinship.
Then the last phase--and what
I'm going to want to say is that
Gates doesn't think we've
reached this.
In other words,
the point of disagreement
between Cooke and Gates is
precisely about this.
The last phase,
which Cooke calls
"intimacy,"
is the freedom to expropriate
any and all models,
not in other words to insist
necessarily on one's own
creative paradigms as a racial
tradition but to expropriate
anything that comes ready to
hand.
Ellison's Invisible
Man, for example,
is a masterpiece of High
Modernism.
It takes freely,
in other words,
from whatever traditions come
to hand and are most readily
available for the kind of work
that Ellison wants to do.
Cooke identifies this perhaps
rather optimistically with what
he calls "intimacy":
in other words,
a merger, a finally achieved
merger of traditions such that--
and this is plainly the ideal
of Virginia Woolf as well--
such that one no longer has to
write as a spokesperson.
One no longer needs to be
concerned with thematizing the
kinds of identity out of which
one's writing has arisen.
One can write just anything one
wants to--
in other words,
the utopian vision of "no
matter who I am,
I have access to absolutely any
forms and themes I care to work
with."
That is the vision of Michael
Cooke,
which Gates,
I think, unfortunately,
rightly feels that we haven't
quite arrived at,
and that's why I deliberately
used the word
"expropriate"
in talking about Cooke's fourth
phase.
If I use models other than
models made available by my own
tradition, I'm not just kind of
pulling them out of the air.
I'm using them with a
calculated purpose.
I always have something in mind
in choosing the model that I
choose.
We're not really quite at
intimacy because self-definition
is still at issue.
You can talk about the High
Modernism of the Invisible
Man all you like,
but think of what the
Invisible Man is about.
The Invisible Man is
still about what it means to be
black.
What is "passing"?
What does it mean in other
words to have this racial
identity?
So that, yes:
traditions, manners,
styles have been expropriated,
but at the same time the
business of writing as an
African American continues,
and it is as much,
after all, a question of
self-definition as it has been
hitherto.
As Gates sees it,
it continues to be the issue.
We use other models.
We need to make them our own.
Otherwise we're just colonized
by them, and then after all
we're back in phase one,
right?
We're back in self-veiling
because, after all,
Phillis Wheatley used other
models.
Phillis Wheatley actually
aspired to the idea that she was
just a poet.
She could write about anything
she wanted to write about--
the tears of Niobe in the
painting by Richard Wilson--
whatever it might be,
she could write about it
because she was just a poet.
That was her great aspiration,
to be received not as
that amazing thing,
a young black slave woman who
could write.
She wasn't interested in that.
She wanted to be a poet,
and so in a certain sense you
can see the problem.
If intimacy is achieved in the
fourth phase,
well, then that's finally just
the realization of what Phillis
Wheatley wanted in the first
phase,
>
and we have to admit,
for all of the complicated
reasons that these critics go
into,
that this is not a moment which
can be said yet to have been
achieved.
Okay.
Now this brings us to Gates's
key concept: what does it mean
to expropriate other people's
traditions,
more particularly the white
tradition,
Here Gates is after all
thinking primarily about
criticism.
How can we do theory and
criticism in the white man's
language?
How can we appropriate or
expropriate for ourselves the
white man's language?
The necessity of bending
language to one's own purposes
is what is emphasized in the
remarkable epigraph on page 1891
that Gates takes from Bakhtin.
This is, it seems to me,
as central a passage in
Bakhtin,
by the way, as anything that we
studied when we were actually
reading Bakhtin,
and I'd like you to make note
of it because I think it really
can illuminate a great deal
that's going on in Bakhtin that
we didn't perhaps fully
articulate at the time.
This is what Bakhtin says:
… language,
for the individual
consciousness,
lies on the borderline between
oneself and the other.
The word in language is half
someone else's.
It becomes "one's
own" only when the speaker
populates it with his own
intention,
his own accent [and you can
hear Gates wanting to emphasize
that word "accent"],
when he appropriates the word,
adapting it to his own semantic
and expressive intention.
Prior to this moment of
appropriation,
the word does not exist in a
neutral and impersonal language
(it is not,
after all, out of a dictionary
that the speaker gets his
words!)
[how true], but rather it
exists in other people's mouths,
in other people's contexts,
serving other people's
intentions: it is from there
that one must take the word,
and make it "one's
own."
Now actually during the course
of his essay,
Gates echoes this sentiment of
Bakhtin by quoting Derrida at
the very top of the right-hand
column on page 1901,
where he says,
"We must master,
as Derrida wrote,
'how to speak the other's
language without renouncing
(our) own."
Now how do you do this?
How do you set about talking
the language you are given?
This isn't, of course,
just a question of the
difference between the races.
It's a question of all of us in
relation to each other.
As Bakhtin says in what you
have already read,
most of the time we're speaking
other people's languages.
It is rare indeed that we can
say, feeling very much like
creative writers when we do so,
that we have somehow wrenched
other people's language out of
its conventional usages and made
it our own,
slightly rewritten it so that
it is truly our own.
So more broadly speaking,
this is the challenge that
faces a theoretical tradition or
a theoretical enterprise,
I should say,
that doesn't want to be just
derivative from what other folks
have already said.
The concept that Gates brings
to bear on this,
because after all he
recognizes, as does Showalter
too,
that the notion of the
sign is probably the
cornerstone of white male
literary theory--
he recognizes that in order to
perform this expropriative act,
he's got to do something with
the notion of the sign,
and so he talks about the way
in which one can signify
on something.
He introduces it very quietly
on page 1900,
the right-hand column,
just seemingly in passing,
near the top of the right-hand
column:
Since writing,
according to Hume,
was the ultimate sign of
difference between animal and
human,
these writers implicitly were
Signifyin(g) upon the figure of
the chain itself…
Notice the accent.
You don't necessarily pronounce
the g:
they were signifyin' on the
chain.
Of course, the great chain of
being, which is hierarchical,
is very different from the
vertical chain of the chain
gang, isn't it?
It's very different from the
chain that holds slaves
together.
That's part of what it means to
"signify on"
something.
At least allegedly,
the "signifier"
in the white male theoretical
tradition is just a kind of
placeholder in a play of
linguistic differences.
The question of the underlying
sociological and cultural basis
of this play and of the way in
which this play takes shape
isn't taken into account--
again, allegedly--
because--well,
in ways that you can probably
grasp from what we've said all
along,
this is slightly to
oversimplify,
but this is the position taken
up.
In any case,
you therefore need to take the
signifier and signify on
it.
Well, what is it to signify on
something?
This is an expression that
Gates takes from the trickster
tradition,
the tradition of African
storytelling in which the weaker
is also the smarter,
and the monkey or Anansi the
Spider--
some of you may remember the
songs of Rafi from your
childhood about Anansi the
Spider--
in which the monkey or the
spider tricks the big,
bad guys, the elephant,
the lion.
All of the bad guys get tricked
because they are stupider,
and the little guy is always
able to signify on them,
to trick them,
and to lie to them without
their realizing what's going on.
This way of talking about
signifying is very much in the
tradition of African-American
folklore and first comes to
public consciousness in a song
by the scat singer Oscar Brown,
Jr., written by Oscar Brown,
Jr., called "The
Signifyin' Monkey."
If I could sing,
I'd sing it to you.
Fortunately,
I can't sing,
but it became extremely popular
and was picked up by various
instrumental jazz groups and was
a staple in the jazz tradition
of the fifties and sixties.
In any case,
Oscar Brown Jr.'s notion of the
signifying monkey is where Gates
takes his essay's title from and
which is where also he gets this
idea of taking somebody else's
discourse out of its context and
insisting on bending it into an
African-American context--
in other words,
a context which is one's own
and not just the context one is
given.
Now the other example of
"signifyin' on"
that Gates gives is the
culminating example of The
Color Purple, and the
conversation about "gettin'
the man out of your eye,"
which is a way of taking back a
problem that exists even within
the African-American tradition.
As Gates has been pointing out,
Wheatley and later Rebecca
Jackson take their models of
education and self-development
from white male figures who have
taught them how to read.
In each case of course,
this is pernicious because the
existence of the white male
figure is very much still in
your eye.
You got to get the man out of
your eye, at least according to
the dialogue Gates quotes from
The Color Purple.
Well, the interesting thing
there is that in a way the issue
of feminist criticism comes back
to haunt Gates's argument
because plainly Shug doesn't
just mean the white man
when she says "the
man."
A big issue in The Color
Purple, of course,
is the emergence of a possible
feminism from social
constructions that aren't just
defined by race;
so that when Gates says
"the man,"
which all of us recognize as
shorthand for "the white
man," can be signified on
by an African-American
tradition,
making it a term of opprobrium,
right?--
"get the man out of your
eye"--
at the same time it can be
signified on by the
feminist tradition,
making it a term of opprobrium
not in a completely different
way,
but in an overlapping and
partially different way.
Gates, in emphasizing the one
as opposed to the other,
is perhaps tilting again toward
a certain imbalance.
Now finally I want to take up
the example,
the most controversial example
in his essay,
one which is a source of
outrage for most readers,
at the bottom of page 1893 in
the left-hand column.
He's been talking about the New
Agrarian moment out of which
there emerged a number of
figures associated with the New
Criticism,
including Robert Penn Warren,
who very early on repudiated
the New Agrarians and became a
politically progressive figure
in his own writing.
Many of you have probably read
All the King's Men,
certainly,
and his poetry as well.
He was an avatar,
a central figure,
in the development of the
thinking of the New Criticism,
which we have briefly studied.
Now Warren wrote a poem called
"Pondy Woods,"
which is quoted completely out
of context by Sterling Brown and
unfairly out of context in the
passage which I'm not going to
read because I don't think I
have the right to speak the
"N-word";
so I'll just have you look at
it--and I'll come back to that
in a minute.
Sterling Brown's response is
also recorded there for you.
Well, the problem is,
from the standpoint of anybody
who's actually read the poem--
but remember in some ways it's
a problem raised by a New
Critical perspective,
and I'll explain what I mean in
a minute--
that expression is spoken by a
buzzard or vulture from--
I forget whether it's Tennessee
or Kentucky.
The episode takes place in
northern Louisiana,
and the buzzard is sitting
expectantly on a tree waiting
for a fugitive slave who has
been chased into the swamp by
his white pursuers to die.
The vulture is sitting
there--well, if it could it
would be--rubbing its hands with
glee waiting for this to take
place.
It's the vulture that says it
in the poem: nothing to do in
other words,
as we say, with the author of
the poem,
Warren, who is writing a
completely sympathetic evocation
of what it's like to be a
fugitive slave in this state of
terrible and overwhelmed panic.
So it seems completely unfair
and it is, I think,
unfair as Sterling Brown took
it up and as Gates then
perpetuates the idea in his own
reference.
The one thing I would add,
however, is that it's a New
Critical idea that we invoke to
say that it's unfair.
It's the New Criticism,
in which Robert Penn Warren was
a participant,
that tells us we shouldn't
confuse speakers in poems with
authors.
In other words,
an author is someone,
according to the New Criticism,
who is dispassionate and who
introduces dramatic voices even
in lyric poems,
voices with which we are merely
confusing ourselves if we
associate them with an author.
Now this is something that we
just take for granted when we
read poems.
All poems for us are to some
degree dramatic monologues on
the model of Browning and others
in the nineteenth century.
We read them that way now,
but it is,
as I say, a New Critical idea,
and it comes back to the
question,
"Who has the right to use
the 'N-word'?"
It's a frequent term used on
the street,
as you know,
in African-American culture,
used almost with a certain
fondness as a form of mutual
greeting,
but at the same time it is a
term that continues rigorously
to be rejected as available to
anyone other than someone who
belongs within this community.
And so that issue lingers.
It's an issue that
Warren--because of course he
wrote long before this
controversy began to arise
around the word--
the controversy really boiled
over precisely at the time of
the banning of Huckleberry
Finn from public schools,
much later, and so there's a
kind of innocence perhaps in
Warren's use of the word.
Nevertheless,
in the critical tradition it's
a question, "Who has the
right to use it?"
This gives rise perhaps to the
suggestion of a certain
insularity in the thinking of
the New Criticism.
Use any model you like:
the model of the Freudian
unconscious, the model of the
political unconscious.
In other words,
we've been reading a lot in
this course about our never
quite saying what we mean to
say,
of our never quite being fully
in control of our discourse
because it bubbles up from the
unconscious, right?
Now if you take a model like
this, even though it's a nasty
buzzard from Kentucky that's
saying what Gates quotes,
nevertheless there is an
author, and it has bubbled up
from the unconscious of that.
Well, what are you going to do
with that?
There's a kind of impasse there.
We feel distinctly and vividly
and even bitterly--
because I love Warren,
I love "Pondy Woods"
and I also am something of a
New Critic--
so we feel a bitterness about
the expropriation,
the "signifying on"
what Warren says in this
fashion.
At the same time,
we have entertained these ideas
of a subliminal author,
not an authority but an author
welling up from below.
If that's the case,
then we have to worry a little
bit about how an expression like
that got into the poem after
all.
I call it a lingering problem
because it strikes me as one of
those moments when probably it
would have been better if Gates
hadn't followed Sterling Brown,
one of those moments when there
is a kind of overkill in the
zeal of argumentation,
but which at the same time we
can't absolutely dismiss out of
hand for the variety of reasons
that I have mentioned.
Okay.
I'll leave it there,
and we'll return to many of
these issues in a new vocabulary
and in new forms when we read
the examples of post-colonial
criticism on Thursday that
you've been assigned.